zuma simplifica la respuesta y escríbela
como número mixto aquí tenemos tres
números mixtos tres enteros un doceavo
más once enteros dos quintos más cuatro
enteros tres quince años y los queremos
sumar si recuerdas el vídeo pasado
sabemos que tres enteros un doceavo lo
puedes escribir como tres enteros más un
doceavo entonces esta suma queda como 3
más un doceavo
+ 11
más dos quintos
+ 315 a 2 y esto es la suma de un montón
de números pero sabemos que cuando
sumamos el orden no nos importa ajá
no importa así que vamos a notar primero
los números enteros es decir este
este
y este
+ 4 y ahora vamos a notar todas las
fracciones que es esta ésta y ésta
es decir más un doceavo
más dos quintos
+ 315 años realmente la suma de los
enteros es muy sencilla tenemos 3 + 11 x
14 + 4
quedan 18 ahora solamente falta sumar la
parte roja que realmente lleva un poco
más de truco
esta es una suma de fracciones y sabemos
que cuando sumamos fracciones debemos
tener el mismo denominador y ese
denominador puede ser el mínimo común
múltiplo de 12 5 y 15 para obtener el
mínimo común múltiplo podemos utilizar
la fuerza bruta agarramos uno de estos
partes por decir el 12 empezamos a ver
cuáles son todos sus múltiplos y vemos
cuál de ellos también es múltiplo de 5 y
de 15 otra manera de obtener el mínimo
común múltiplo
con la factorización prima de 12 5 y 15
y porque quisiéramos la factorización
prima pues resulta que el mínimo común
múltiplo debe de tener la factorización
prima de cada uno de estos cuates para
asegurarme que me está siguiendo vamos a
obtener la factorización prima de 12 12
se puede descomponer como 2 por 6 y 6 se
puede descomponer como dos por tres
así que 12 es lo mismo que 2 por dos por
tres es decir 2 por 2 por 3 es la
descomposición prima de 12 luego
55 se puede escribir como 1 por 5 es
decir la factorización prima de 55 y
pues que estoy diciendo 5 es un número
primo entonces él mismo es su propia
factorización es decir 55 ahora para 15
tenemos que su factorización prima es 3
por 5 porque 3 y 5 ya son números primos
ahora nuestro denominador debe de tener
al menos 212 si un 3 vamos a escribirlo
debe de tener 2 12 y 13 para que
contenga el 12 también debe de tener un
un 5 y también debe de tener al 3 y el 5
pero el 3 y el 5 ya lo tenemos el 3
el 3 viene de la factorización prima de
12 en si toda esta parte viene de la
factorización prima de 12 pero también
el 3 está en la factorización prima de
15 toda esta parte está en la
factorización prima de 15 así que este
número contiene la factorización prima
de 12 de 5 y de 15 así que ya podemos
reescribir nuestras fracciones con este
nuevo denominador y este número es 2 por
2 4 por 3 12 por 5 60 así que 60 es el
mínimo común múltiplo de 12 5 y 15 así
que todas estas fracciones tendrán a 60
como denominador ahora para llegar del
12 al 60 tuvimos que multiplicar por 5
entonces tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 55 por 1
para llegar de 5 a 60
tuvimos que multiplicar por 12 así que
tenemos que multiplicar 2 por 12 que es
y para llegar de 15 a 60 tuvimos que
multiplicar esta fracción por 4 entonces
hacemos 4 por 3 que es 12 y listo ahora
tenemos 18 más
esta suma de fracciones que tiene como
denominador a 60 y como numerador tiene
a 5 24 que es 29 más 12 que da 41
la fracción 40 y 16 centavos que hasta
donde a mí me consta no se puede
simplificar y ahora sí ya terminamos
porque 18 enteros más 41 centavos es lo
mismo que 18 enteros
60 años